to your right
[Applause]
travis scott totally lovingly trolled
kylie jenner
in the cutest way possible it's fun
earlier this week the 28 year old rapper
hit up his insta story to share
this sweet pick with their two-year-old
daughter stormi webster
grinning ear to ear sitting on her
daddy's shoulders
the caption can't wait for holidays your
mommy photos be blurry
listen travis forbes just named the 23
year old makeup mogul the highest
earning celebrity of the year after she
raked in
590 million dollars it's not like
that was handed to her she figured that
all out she can't be good at
everything she made her own money for
over a decade
she put it in the bank she saved every
nickel and then when she decided she
really
you know decided on what she wanted to
do she spent
her money on a venture that could have
gone south or north
and it did really well that impressive
number was largely a result of kylie
selling 51 percent of her cosmetics line
to cody earlier this year
i'm excited about it the reality star
was the only woman to appear in the top
10 of the celebrity earners list and
travis
he made the list too coming in at number
82
after earning 39.5 million dollars in
2020.
[Music]
kylie and travis have been spending lots
of time together recently
in october the keeping up with the
kardashians star shared snaps from a
steamy at-home photo shoot with storm's
dad
later that month kylie skipped her
sister kim kardashian's 40th birthday
getaway trip
due to work commitments and while her
famous fam was abroad
she and travis enjoyed a fun weekend
trip together with their little girl
and earlier this month the kardashian
jenner crew included travis
in their stone-faced facetime call gone
viral
what's going on